افاد مراسل الجزيره بسقوط شهداء ومصابين
داخل مقر الصناعه الذي يضم نازحين غربي
مدينه خان يونس بعد سقوط قذيفه مدفعيه
واندلاع حريق كبير واشتعال النار في خيام
النازحين هذا وبث ناشطون صورا تظهر اندلاع
حريق كبير في كليه التعليم المهني او مبنى
الصناعه التابع للاونروا في
المدينه
[موسيقى]
عن هذا الحريق تبعنا صوره الان وما خلفه
حتى الان من شهداء وجرحى وضحايا معنا من
خار يونس مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر
اسماعيل ماذا عن اخر المستجدات فيما يتعلق
بهذا الحريق وهذا القصر الذي
طاله نعم القصف استهدف هذا المقر مقر مركز
التدريب التابع للوكاله في غرب محافظه
خانيونس وهذا المقر كنا قد تحدثنا بانه
قريب من اليات الاحتلال التي توغلت في تلك
المنطقه في الاجزاء الغربيه من المحافظه
واطلقت قذيفه باتجاه هذا المقر هناك شهداء
بالامس وهناك شهداء ايضا في هذا اليوم في
هذا القصف وعدد من الاصابات الكوادر
الطبيه او هناك كان طبيب او طبيبين داخل
هذا البقر للتعامل مع المرضى وهم لا
يستطيعون التعامل مع عدد كبير من الاصابات
وقع خلال عمليات الصف التي قامت بها قوات
الاحتلال هناك عمليات تنسيق تجري بين
الحين والاخر من اجل تامين وصول سيارات
الاسعاف باتجاه هذا المقار لنقل الاصابات
والتعاون مع هذه الاصابات الى مستشفى ناصر
ونتحدث بان مستشفى ناصر ايضا معرض لحصار
شديد من قبل اليات الاحتلال ما يعني ان
تحرك الاسعافات باتجاه مستشفى ناصر فيه
خطوره ايضا على الطواقم ويحتاج الى تنسيق
جديد لوصول هذه الاسعافات الى مستشفى ناصر
لكن قد يتم التنسيق لوصول هذه السيارات
اما لمستشفى ناصر او حتى مستشفيات مدينه
رفح في ابو يوسف النجار او مستشفى الكويت
في غرب مدينه رفح حتى هذه اللحظه عمليه
التنسيق تجري هناك حديث من اجل ان الوكاله
هي من ترعى هذا التنسيق لتامين وصول
الاسعافات الى هذا المقام نتحدث ب ان ال
الحريق ما زال شابا في ح في هذه اللحظات
في تلك ال في ذلك المركز وهناك لابد من
تدخل ايضا دفاع مدني من اجل الصول الوصول
الى هذا المكان لاطفاء هذا الحريق الذي شب
في ذلك المكان خاصه شب انه في في مقر
الصناعه او
تحديدا بنايه بها منجره داخل مركز تدريب
خان يونس وهنا نتحدث بان عم من كان داخل
هذا المركز او هذا المبنى او هذا الم هذا
المصنع او هذا المنشاه اسماعيل هل من
تقديرات عن اعداد من كانوا بداخله خاصه
وانه مركز لجو
وايوا نعم نتحدث ان بشكل عام هو مركز
التدريب بكامله يحتوي على عديد البنايات
وعديد الغرف وايضا في ساحه هذا المركز
هناك خيام للنازحين نتحدث عن اكثر من
10000 نازح داخل هذا المقر والمواطنون
اتخذوا ايضا مباني الاداره التابعه لهذا
المركز ك كغرف للايواء خاصه من نزحوا من
شمال قطاع غزه مدينه غزه في بدايه الحرب
البريه على شمال قطاع غزه ونزعوا الى هذا
المكان واتخذوا من هذه الغرف وكذلك
المنشات اتخذوها جميعها كمراكز ايواء
ووضعوا اغراضهم الشخصيه ومقتنياتهم
الشخصيه في ذلك في تلك الاماكن سواء كانت
منجر او غيرها اوما شابه ذلك من هذه
المنشات تم استخدامها من قبل النازحين
هناك حديث عن اكثر من 30 اصابه حتى هذه
اللحظه داخل هذا ال داخل هذه المنشاه او
المنجره في مقر مركز تدريب خان يونس
وعمليه التنسيق حتى هذه اللحظه لازالت
جاريه وهناك حديث بان ت تم تم التنسيق لكن
لم تصل حتى لحظه سيارات الاسعاف نتابع
بالتاكيد مع مديره مركز التدريب راويه حلس
في المكان والتي ستتواجد في المكان وهي
وجهت نداءات استغاثه تقريبا قبل ساعه من
اجل التوصل او وصول سيارات الاسعاف الى
المكان ومحاوله تامين ممرات امنه للنازحين
للخروج من هذا الم قار الذي يعني تحاول
قوات الاحتلال الاقتراب منه وهي ايضا
قريبه جدا منه هناك عشرات الامتار فقط
تفصل ما
بينيه الاحتلال وهذا المقار الذي يحتوي
على بوابه واحده وهي البوابه الغربيه
والبوابه الغربيه مطله ايضا على اماكن
تواجد اليه الاحتلال طيب هذه نقطه مهمه
انا اعود بك قبل ان يتم استهداف هذه
المنشاه كما نشاهد في هذه
الصور هل كانت هناك اشتباكات
قريبه او ملاصقه للمبنى ما الذي كان يحدث
قبل استهدافه كما كما شاهدنا ونتابع في
هذه الصوره وما خلفته من حريق ومن
دمار هذه هذا المكان كان المواطنون
يحاولون ان يعبروا عبر عبر هذا المكان او
يسلكوا هذا هذا الشارع بالقرب من منطقه
الصناعه حتى يصلوا الى المناطق الغربيه
لمحافظه خان يونس وهذا المكان من امام
الساحه الغربيه لهذا المقر حتى منطقه
البحر وهو الشارع شارع الرشيد مساحه فارغه
لا تصلح لعمليات القتال ان كان الاحتلال
يتضرع بين هذ منطقه اشتباك ليست منطقه
اشتباك لان منطقه فارغه ولا تصلح ان تكون
منطقه اشتباك لان اي حركه للمواطنين
المدنيين هناك خطوره عليه فما بالك حينما
يكون من يتحرك في هذه المنطقه هم مقاومون
وعناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه بالتاكيد سيتم
استهدافهم لذلك هذه المنطقه مطله او على
امتدادها حتى حتى ساح بحر خانيونس هي
منطقه مفتوحه وهي ايضا على مراى قوات
واليات الاحتلال ومطله ايضا على هذا
المقار اليات الاحتلال السوا تتواجد بال
المقربه من هذا المكان وهي مطله بشكل تام
وبشكل واضح على هذا المكان حتى حركه
المواطنين قد تكون مصوه لدى قوات الاحتلال
في محيط هذا المكان عموما النيران ما زالت
مستعله في هذا المقر التابع لوكاله الامم
المتحده وهناك الاصابات سيتم التعامل معها
من بعض اتكم الطبيه وهم اطباء كانوا قد
تواجدوا داخل هذا المقر لتقديم الخدمات
الطبيه البسيطه للمرضى فما ذلك حينما يكون
الامر بالتعامل مع جرحى واصابات تحتاج الى
تعامل خاص من قبل الاطق الطبيه وهذا يحتاج
الى مستشفيات كبرى حتى يتم التعامل مع هذه
الاصابات